what does this mean to you to have Tyler
dedicate this stage I feel like there's
a lot of people he should have done
first before me a lot of folks why would
you because because if he doesn't do it
it won't get done so I don't mind
waiting my turn your turn was tonight
well apparently apparently but you know
there's a lot of folks Perl you know
probably there's a lot of a lot of a lot
of people that who should be shining in
our in our spirits as part of what we do
but I I love that he's you know that
he's got Cecily lovely I die and ready
to go you know so it's it's great but I
feel there's other folks that I would
out so I would just say to him I'll just
give him a list you're crazy because
you're on the top of list and that's why
tonight whoo I'm in time you know that's
the top of the list right there you know
that's the top of the list so when you
think about Cecily do you think of all
of those women that nobody ever
acknowledged this is just a big tiniest
piece of it because there are so many
that came before that no one ever
acknowledged so the fact that he's
acknowledging folks now is great and
that's why I feel like there's a lot
there's a lot of Hattie McDaniel yeah
you know maybe those stages are coming
all right
you really do officiate over what can be
a wild ride on the view all the time how
I don't think about it no you know my my
day consists of waking up happy to be
above ground and anything that I get
after that it's sugar candy
how scary was that bout with pneumonia
well when somebody says you bout to die
it's it kind of wakes you up you know
but it you know we think maybe part of
getting sick and also having it
exacerbated per
by vaping so you know learning that you
know we got to do things differently now
thank you honey
[Music]